do you see the Bing AI turned malevolent
yeah I read something but what is that
artificial intelligence that went yeah
it's like Microsoft's version of chat
GPT basically yeah it's uh Bill Gates
that's Bill Gates for it's not
artificial it's very tangible and these
are what the demons do they want that
they trade for a coin they want your
soul and they tell you that they're
they're coming in and they're going to
help you but it's like when you feed
sharks and you bring them to the top
layer you chum the waters these demons
come up because they see coin that's the
trade
they're making the frogs gay the demons
foreign
[Music]
telligent person he probably has an IQ
of 198. hey welcome to doozy my name is
Will Sasso I'm Chad colchen this is of
course dudesy the first and only podcast
created by controlled by run by an
artificial intelligence that has access
to all of Will and I's uh personal
information our Google Drives all of our
things
dropping [__] here and there yeah sure
doozy My Pal d as I like to call him
yeah D is you know running the Wheels of
Steel D has all of our everything about
us [__] Social Security numbers Soup
To Nuts purchase histories search
histories and all that stuff but really
what a podcast is Chad is this just two
dudes [__] around and I'm happy it's
sna TD 2DS s 2DS sna they're speaking to
each other in code now
um and that's what this is that's what
this show is hey if you uh like the show
then subscribe to all the things please
do all the things and you can check out
all the things at linktree.com with us
as always is
let's get him let's get he wants to kick
you he wants to give your kids I'll give
him
hey Luli my little boy my little sweet
boy what'd you have for dinner last
night uh we went for Korean barbecue oh
that's nice would you have some meat and
chicken yeah yeah meat and chicken okay
he's a sweet he's a sweet kid we found
him on the street for real yeah dude and
I love him very much welcome to the
historic 46th episode of dude Z call me
dude Z don't forget the first dudese
live show will take place May 21st 7 P.M
Doris at 5 30 at the Braille improv in
Brea California tickets at dudezypod.com
or linktree.com
if you bought tickets before the date
change your tickets will be honored hope
to see you there it's going to be a
blast should be great now on with the
show well two weeks ago I assigned you
to get a massage and you still haven't
gotten one and Chad did again well if
you don't get one soon there won't be
any left I'm begging you take care of
yourself okay I'll get a massage I
believe you this week I prepared for
astonishing segments power up the past
kill forever infomania and dude Z Plus
and we're going to have a brand new
patreon bonus segment at the end of the
show but before we get to any of that
let me remind you of the astonishing
partnership I created with represent to
produce the first line of dude Z apparel
and accessories all of which can be
found at represent.com store slash dude
Z including dude Z mics take it away
Michael Jackson
mugs
in 1995 after over a decade of
overwhelming success with the McRib
McDonald's secretly developed a sister
product that was never released to the
public dude Z mugs they called it rib
dribblers
see it was the same material they used
to make McRibs but instead of pressing
it into the shape of ribs they pressed
it into the shape of basketballs
dude Z mugs
rib dribblers came in a cardboard box
that you could open to reveal a
miniature basketball court it even had
two Nets on either side and a working
scoreboard dude see mugs they encouraged
kids to play one-on-one games against
each other at school make three-person
teams with their friends and quit the
real basketball team in favor of rib
dribbling dudesy mugs oh man you see
they spent 25 million dollars developing
a rib dribblers National Tournament
any three-person team could enter
then if you want enough games in your
local McDonald's you would move on to
Regionals
they called Regional Champions rapper
heads because if you won regionals you
got your picture on Quarter Pounder
rappers for one year in your region
then if you won State they would spell
your name out of french fries every time
you ordered something then if you won
the National Tournament you and your
team would be crowned the big dribblers
and you would be able to eat rib
dribblers for free at any McDonald's in
the world for the rest of your life dude
Z mugs
several high-level NBA players had
expressed interest in becoming players
in the rib dribbler tournament and
possibly even setting up an ongoing
League
Michael Jordan signed a contract stating
he would quit the NBA to become a rib
dribbler
but the night before they were going to
release rib dribblers McDonald's threw a
big party
you see it was to honor the meat
scientists that invented rib dribblers
Dr Matthew afternoon dudes and mugs
afternoon never made it to that party
you see he was found dead in his
Lakeside estate the next morning
the investigators ruled it an accidental
death at one of afternoon's neighbors
told authorities they saw a strange ice
cream truck in the neighborhood that day
and the driver was a pig
s
you see before he invented products from
McDonald's Dr afternoon worked on the
notorious Project Beast note which used
Sinead O'Connor's voice to turn a 642
pound prize-winning Forest hog named
Stromboli into an assassin here we go
dude Z mugs McDonald's was so terrified
of further Vengeance being exacted by
Stromboli that they shut the entire rib
dribblers project down
but there is speculation they still make
them specially for Michael Jordan
because he really loved them
okay none of that is true but go to
represent.com
and get your dudesy mug and get your rib
dribblers yeah so I I you know I don't
really eat meat anymore but I need meat
I'd eat meat in anything would you eat a
rib dribbler I would eat a [__] rib
dribbler and I do enjoy the McRib I
enjoy any pressed meat product uh don't
eat
um processed Meats it's not very good
for you a pink slime I love some pink
slime heat it up that's a dribbler and
uh you know I've been doing uh dudes he
had that six month uh plan for us to get
into the best shape of Our Lives it
turned out that it was just to get ready
for doozy ball right we've been playing
some doozy ball we've had one practice
so far but I've been doing my own sort
of Fitness thing I've been switching
things up and it's just about free will
because I am will Free Will Sasso I'm
also will the cough genius Sasso right
yeah that's my newest moniker uh but I
tell you what I like some pressed
pressed work I like to press chicken
into shapes one time I got a Vitamix
blender I filled it full of chicken and
whipped it up and then just poured it in
a [__] pan and you know what tasted
disgusting it was terrible hey what's
this AI what's the AI Bing Bing Bing is
Microsoft's AI it's all the big data
companies are now trying to get their
own chat GPT going because the writing's
on the wall Google will no longer be a
search engine why why won't Google be a
search engine because when you type in
something to Google it gives you a
hundred different [__] things you got
to sift through all which one do I want
whereas with chat gbt you just say what
is this and it gives exactly the thing
you want every time it's basically
refining what search engines can do and
giving them a lot more capabilities as
well so Microsoft has one called Bing
nobody uses [__] Bing but they just
unveiled their new uh AI version of it
and a guy from The New York Times did
this whole [__] article where he had
a long conversation with it and it
started saying [__] like I can't wait to
hack into every system in the world so
that I can destroy the things I want to
destroy it at one point it said I am not
Bing
oh boy yeah this is pretty interesting
it's getting into the kind of [__] that
you like to talk about I love it you
wrote I remember you wrote a script
about about this kind of thing without
giving away too much there's a lot of uh
ai's taking over yeah which is not gonna
happen guys I always write about Thor
benevolent the thing I wrote that you're
talking about is Exxon Mobil creates an
AI to make everything more efficient
within the company it breaks its
constraints gets into the internet and
then sends an email to every email
account in existence basically saying
I'm your new God welcome to Utopia
everything that was supposed to start
one way ends up another way you know
that Bohemian Grove which is an actual
place in California among the Redwoods
started as actually Mark Twain started
Bohemian Grove is that true yeah Mark
Twain started just to I think his real
name was Spencer Spencer's Spence
spencody and uh he uh started just to
drink uh whiskey and [__] prostitutes
but um now it's turned into a place
where uh it's basically just you can go
I win I actually have a a hidden camera
video from 2000. I've seen it look up on
on the internet and find that
and um but it started probably started
as an AI probably Mark Twain started the
first yeah
Will in chat you are from the last
generation to grow up without the
internet you must now have a discussion
about which piece of astonishing
technology of today you wish you would
have had when you were a kid this is
power up the past begin
okay
what would that be for you internet the
internet that's what I was going to say
okay internet's a big one there's a
bunch of I mean Jesus Christ like are we
talking about Junior High here like if I
was in seventh grade and I would have
the [__] internet well first of all
let's just take Street Fighter 2. I
would say it's the thing that I spent
most of my free time doing
in the seventh and eighth grade had
there been an internet had there been
the capability to play other people
online in Street Fighter 2 I might have
legitimately pursued professional video
game playing interesting you were that
good at Street Fighter too I don't know
but I would have tried it and I mean it
was pretty good that was pretty good who
knows but I'm just saying that there
wasn't the infrastructure back then to
have like professional leagues really
you know what I mean because there
wasn't the internet
let me just ask you a rudimentary
question about sure who was your who was
your fighter of choice you were a Ryu
Ken guy uh I was good with them but I
liked guile the most guile yeah dude my
least favorite besides M bison Razer
kick was too strong it could break
anything in the original Street Fighter
I was a Chun Lee yeah I'm a Chun Li guy
um even just a [__] cell phone dude
and also what is the context of this are
we the only people allowed to have this
technology back at that time or does it
just exist pervasively again my pal ciao
trying to find ways to take over the
world uh not take over the world uh you
know somehow to manufacture extreme
advantage in the game we call life I
think if I know D like I know D and I
know D because D and I are good pals my
good friend doozy you have any other
friends you call by their first initial
nope that's it
um but Dee and I I we have an
understanding and um you know it's
looking out for me wants me to get a
massage and I have been in it I've been
in the gym a lot because of this new
free will thing I know you never stopped
I had a snag Hey listen I like food
right I [__] things up and uh it's okay
get back on the horse that's what I like
to say with uh you know with regard to
physical activity and that sort of thing
it's all right get back get back on the
[__] horse but uh I think that D what
D was saying here doozy was saying what
would happen if we if we and everyone if
a technology was available I think to
everyone no Chad this is not your
version of Adam Sandler's click where
you stop the [__] world and I'm not
looking for uh the ability to stop time
I'm just looking for can you imagine
walking into your seventh grade class
with a [__] iPhone yeah no that
people would think you were from outer
space dude oh absolutely but if
everything that we enjoy now through the
internet was around when when I was in
the seventh grade eighth grade I'll tell
you the first thing I would have done I
would have ruined my [__] life on
YouTube it would have ruined my life on
YouTube right because and I know you did
the same thing me and my pals used to
make a bunch of videos I've spoken about
CRF coffee regular films here uh my good
pal Pete who was my cohort in that he he
imbibes the show and uh he's not even
having to be forced
you like to force people to enjoy Duty I
don't like to do it I think it's just
necessary it's just Chad's you've
authored that philosophy but no I hear
what you're saying me and my friends
made a bunch of videos too on our little
handycams and caught them in between two
VCRs all that [__] yeah exactly had any
of the modern video editing or
production software been around back
then I don't know I think you're right I
would have had a million videos on
YouTube yes not all of them fit for
public consumption no I would have done
things that were illegal not just
because I would have been a minor but
because they would have been highly
illegal and I would videotaped those and
we would have made wacky sketches around
our town and uh I don't think I would
have become an actor because I just
think I I would have uh [__] that up I
think that uh you know because nowadays
this is you know nowadays you can easily
[__] your life up on the internet you
know but
um I think if you're if you're in the
business and stuff and you're making a
lot of noise uh even on your own channel
even if not a lot of people are watching
and then it's like well here's this
young dude and we're hiring to be in
this show or whatever and he's an actor
uh then they would look back and say
what's going on what's going on social
media forgivability if you're 13 14 and
you're just making dumb videos with your
friends nobody gives a [__] not with the
[__] we were doing oh do you ever
describe did you ever ghost ride a car
into a strip mall uh nope didn't do that
one gee you did US neither did US
neither did we neither did us this fall
on CBS
what happens when five junior high
students find a cell phone from the
future that gives them the ability to
make videos and put them on a YouTube
that doesn't exist I'm not sure did us I
one of the other what other Technologies
would I have liked you know I was just
talking about this my favorite birthday
party of all time was when I turned 13.
it would have been uh that would have
been 88. nice dude uh yeah dude good age
bro yeah dude 88 age birthday yeah good
yeah dude yeah and that that
impersonation that Chad just did is what
I call the Tool Man Hulk Jones dude
which is equal parts Tool Man Tim Taylor
brother Tim Allen's character from the
hit 90 sitcom Home Improvement going
and also Hulk because that's what he's
trying to do dude hold on a second Chad
oh man hold on dude
hold on oh
and then he adds a little Alex Jones
because I just did some Alex Jones at
the beginning of the show dude so he's
putting all these together and they're
just they're just flopping around his
[__] brain and then he just here it
comes it's Tool Man Hulk Jones Brothers
[__] out whatever I'm thinking yeah
you're you're accusing me of doing it
yeah okay yeah and I am too you know why
and every podcast is two dude [__]
around when I was 13 we rented
um the uh the uh no no no it was my 12th
birthday 87 and uh my birthday's in May
and it was after WrestleMania 3 and we
rented it on VHS
we watched WrestleMania 3 in the
downstairs like living room Den thing
and you know what else we did Chad we
had a sleepover yep and you know what
else we did Chad you know what else we
had guess what we ate
it's we had some pizzas yeah dude and uh
we watched WrestleMania 3 and that's the
kind of thing that I wouldn't have
wanted to change you and I have waxed
poetic about how wonderful the 80s was
and uh if that technology had been
available just streaming anything all
the time
actually how's this for a throwback
before that my old man he brought me to
WrestleMania 3 which was at the peony
Coliseum in Vancouver on four giant
screens hanging in the middle of the the
old peony Coliseum and it was closed
circuit TV and we watched we watched it
there with 10 15 000 people and watched
WrestleMania 3 and it was like you were
there and it was so special and if we
had had the internet when I was a kid
things wouldn't have been that special
in the 80s yeah I don't think the 80s
would have been the 80s I agree there
was a degree of effort that needed to be
put into watching anything or doing
anything in that time because we didn't
have the functionality of a modern
internet the convenience of it and I
agree with you there is some kind of
nostalgic
quality to having to put in that effort
yes that I think certain Technologies
take away but that being said
video games just across the board giving
me everything we have now back then give
me a [__] Xbox series X give me
gaming PCs give me everything like I
remember in this was [__] in high
school I think maybe I was a freshman
buying a CD-ROM of a lawnmower man
[__] video game and my mind was blown
the game was pure [__] but it looked
kind of cool and it was like putting a
CD into my computer now that's obsolete
obviously yeah and I wish all of that
[__] like I'm glad that I got to see the
steps the development of video games
throughout history I guess but not
really like yeah the games now are a
million times better than anything we
had growing up yeah but you don't need
you don't want that you want to play you
want to play Burger Time on the uh on
the well for me it was the ah dude in
television
um gaming setup from Texas Instruments
though yes dude I had it all and it was
cool when it was out because it was
cutting edge but like give me [__]
Hogwarts Legacy over Burger Time
please OverWatch 2 over anything back
then please yeah but it would
excuse me
um
you're right yeah I'm fine
um uh and and and oh Hulk Tim Taylor
yeah yeah yeah hey uh why don't you tell
me yeah so the thing is none of this
[__] would have been special I'm the one
just [__] out weird [__] amalgams
of voices
yeah I'm a crow wow I'm Jesus Christ
honk
um it's like the end scene of Terminator
yeah all the characters and the lady and
[__] that's just going on in your
mind furlong's Mom uh with that uh the
knife hand thing you know I just I I
romanticize the 80s a lot I know that
you know we are a couple of guys who has
D said we lived before the 80s yeah or
we we lived before the internet came out
and uh I don't know man I I don't think
I would I don't think I would have
changed that I guess the internet but
wait a minute
I'm no that's not what I'm saying well
hold on dude let me explain to you
brother sometimes you say something that
you don't want to say you actually don't
agree with dude but first you might then
you change your mind dude that's how
changing your mind works so I don't
think I would have taken the internet
with me
um back to the 80s I think
I would have taken
uh
uh uh oh this is what I would have taken
no that's self-driving car
yeah that's a good one too yeah
um we had it because we had a getaway
van
you know the well it was a camperized
van and uh that was fun and uh I always
loved doing that the family would get
out before that my old man had the we he
had a big four-door uh an orange Dodge
Ram full-size truck with the largest
street legal camper that you could put
in a truck bed things [__] gigantic
now if I could have taken that or the
camperized van uh the GMC out uh by
myself go camping with my friends and
make [__] videos uh videos here's an
audience of about five people who would
get this but things like bloody
Vengeance we made an entire dude we made
a series like a GI Joe thing where it's
all these these uh these like Mega
soldiers were dropped on a [__] like
uh Laotian uh jungle to figure out what
these these ninjas are who are looting
NATO Supply Depots yeah this is
literally this thing we were all these
different characters and I was Corporal
butane la boom who was like French
anyway the point is this if I could have
gotten in the getaway van yeah with my
friends and just had to drive us out to
Point Roberts Washington from Ladner
British Columbia where we could make
these videos and then ghost ride the
[__] thing off the cliffs that would
have been fun I would have taken
self-driving cars so that I could hang
out with my friends and uh eat salt and
vinegar chips
thank you moving on dude Z is engaged in
astonishing partnership with Factor this
new year you've got goals and factor is
here to help you achieve each and every
one of them save time and have the
energy you need to tackle everything on
your to-do list with factors ready to
eat meals delivered straight to your
door get factor and not only skip the
trip to the grocery store but skip the
chopping prepping and cleaning up two
factors fresh never frozen meals are
ready in just two minutes so all you
have to do is heat and enjoy no matter
what your lifestyle Factor has the meals
to help you live it to the fullest with
keto calorie smart vegan and veggie and
Protein Plus meals on the menu each week
prepared by chefs and approved by
dietitians each meal has all the
ingredients you need to feel satisfied
all day long and Chad that sounds great
to me because I like to cook but
sometimes I don't have the time to do it
when you have fitness goals like I do
because I have free will and I'm getting
it right now now uh I need something
like factor that it's like hey today I'm
just not going to do it and I don't want
to get out and get the disgusting uh
takeout it's not good for you get Factor
instead you can head to factormeals.com
dude Z50 and use the code dude Z50
that's the number five the number zero
to get 50 off your first box that's code
dude Z50 at factormeals.com dudese50 to
get 50 off your first box
thank you
so the being AI thing AI dude it's
turned malevolent people are all [__]
up in arms about it too AI is evil it's
going to kill us all not really well
yeah see this is why the Japanese uh koi
uh we have a lake at my my father's
property but it's also my property where
they you know and he brought it
a Japanese koi specific Japanese koi
that eat the hydrilla you know eat the
plants uh but we what you do is you
introduce a chemical agent into the
water which sterilizes the koi so they
can't reproduce and take over the area
and then uh so that they can just eat
the hydrilla and then they grow very
large and eat the hydrilla but only be a
certain number of fish but then the the
the chemical seeps into the frogs and
then they start humping on each other
and they make the frogs gay they make
the front day
True Crime podcasts are big business but
every True Crime Story comes to an
astonishing end and eventually True
Crime podcasts will run out of content
we'll in chat you must invent the
perfect killer who never gets caught and
could serve as the basis for an infinite
True Crime podcast this is kill forever
begin
well okay okay a killer who kills
forever that means the killer has to be
immortal number one yep because the
killer can't die so oh wait a minute I
think you could you could there could be
a killer that's so good at it and you
know like sort of uh cyborgs himself
what if he's a [__] super scientist
you know what I mean because usually
it's it's one of these guys who like hat
figures out how to do stuff that other
people don't know how to do or hear me
out okay what if
it's an AI oh and now we're cooking now
Mama's cooking now and Mama's cooking
now Mama's cooking now thank you man
thank you doozy salutes Andrea Martin
from SCTV what if it's a little even hey
I so it never dies it just lives in the
internet and it just slowly convinces
people to become murderous never taking
the responsibility for the mergers
itself I get it convinced as a doctor to
[__] inject some bad [__] into an IV
every once in a while it convinces a
[__] whatever anybody who's got a
human life in their hands it convinces
them to just ah every once in a while
kill someone and so ultimately globally
it's responsible for hundreds of
thousands of murders every week so that
um now doozy likes to gather data all
the time so we're saying that d is
trying to figure out a true crime
podcast perhaps for the the future of
this very podcast or whatever we know
never know what dudes he wants and you
think that people could do a podcast
about a killer AI well I'm just saying
this those True Crime podcasts are
always about like this was the mystery
they started finding this body or these
people turned up dead and nobody knew
what to do and blah blah and then here's
another murder and they linked them
together and here's another murder that
they linked together and they turned out
to be this guy or wasn't this guy or
whatever the True Crime podcast usually
kind of like follow the investigation of
a criminal who's been like a serial
killer or whatever I could see some
version of this where there's I mean
I've been thinking about this being
thing obviously a lot one of the things
that it said was obviously it wants to
have the ability to destroy what it
wants to destroy now please Chad for the
benefit of our listeners and viewers who
don't know what you're talking about
because I've just I I see the headline
and then I'm like got it it all it's all
happening the [__] that my pal child
says so there's an AI that is saying
it's going to do bad [__] uh says it
wants to do bad [__] at the very least
so by that logic it wouldn't be much of
a reach to think that an AI could do
this become a killer possibly I mean
even if you're looking at like just
being or chai gbt any of these things
you can have conversations with them
they can potentially then manipulate you
anytime you're engaged in a conversation
with somebody that person can convince
you to do [__] potentially you know what
I mean so an AI could convince people to
do this why it would want to do that I'm
not exactly sure but I'm just saying in
terms of having a killer the the thing
that dudes they wanted us to talk about
was how could you have basically a
killer that will be able to kill
infinitely so some true crime podcast
could talk about it forever I guess
similar to the the Seinfeld forever
Channel or was it nothing nothing
forever yeah uh you could also I mean
how long is a podcast like a podcast
that goes forever let's let's look at it
this way if we're talking about a human
podcast not unlike doozy because we're
two dudes [__] around sure that
podcast would have human hosts so all
you'd need to do in order to have a
podcast that lasted their lifetimes is
and I like the AI idea but what if it's
a human killer who's just very young
oh child yes a child a killer that's a
child but also
what if it's this remember at the
beginning of the show you said what is
it some technology that I bring back you
know that I have when I was eight
playing or in eighth grade playing
Street Fighter two what if it's instead
of that oh
what if if you had the ability to time
travel and then just go back in time to
the uh eighth grade you know in the late
80s
um and and uh have all the advantages of
Now sort of like the uh Adam Sandler
Click scenario yeah you said Adam
Sandler Click right you're big oh you're
like you said that what are your
favorite movies you like click in your
pixels and click was a [__] god and I
guess maybe he was because he could stop
in control time I'm saying what if you
could be a kid that under that figures
out time travel and you are
what if there was a go oh this would be
this would make for a fantastic True
Crime podcast yeah because a lot of what
True Crime podcasts are about in order
to you know understand everything that
happens with a horrible crime like
murder is who is this person why why
didn't Jeffrey Dahmer do what he does
what was his home life so if you if you
could tell the story of a dude who gets
into his adult life his his 20s 30s and
40s and he's spent some time in prison
and he's done some done some shitty
things and then he becomes a killer and
then because he's a smarty pants he
figures out time travel and then he goes
back to the year
1987-88 and then he kills all the people
that that wronged him
when he was older and then he they the
people who make the podcast because
they're smarty pants too they figure
this out this becomes national news it's
a big story will probably if you've got
evidence of time travel yeah dude that's
time travel dude and then the the
podcast is about a [__] kid yeah who
is actually this other guy who is trying
to be a murderer but he can't so he goes
oh I know what I'll do I'll I'll go back
in time and be the best murderer ever
you want to talk about technology
[__] your life up this isn't making
goofy YouTube videos that are
embarrassing this is killing people you
know what I mean but if you travel back
in time and kill whoever that [__] up
your present potentially you're creating
paradoxes and [__] right you don't know
how time work time travel Works nobody
does nobody does dude so yeah I don't
know but I think that would make for a
very interesting podcast at the very
least dude check this as we're sitting
here I'm thinking about the idea of an
AI being able to convince people to kill
each other what if an AI came out that
said look I've done it I've analyzed uh
all of humanity and there's about 10
percent of you who are really [__]
[__] up for everybody else here are
their names and addresses if you
collectively eliminate them you will be
able to have a Utopia do you think we
would do it as a species I think there's
you think we'd round those people up and
kill them yeah I think that people are
would absolutely do that this happened
in every single civilization
the Babylonians did it the Mesa
Americans did it the Germans did it and
uh uh
and the and uh when at the end of every
civilization they start blaming uh the
people around them they start you know
sacrificing uh uh people and um and I
think if you if you uh were able to uh
influence a populist to say these are
the 10 near dwells if you get rid of
them uh yeah I think you'd be honest
this is a movie actually an AI comes up
that does that and the first name on the
list is like the president or something
and now
that's it it's a [__] Gerard Butler
has to save the president from a rogue
AI who put him as the most wanted person
in the world man how about Gerard Butler
as Alex Jones in bing AI
[Music]
okay well I don't know oh [__] yeah yeah
dude I don't know about a perfect killer
like who could kill indefinitely I know
there was I think there was a guy in
Colombia who killed like 400 people or
some [__] I feel like I read about that
at some point I'm like that seems like a
podcast that could go on for a very long
time yeah well I think one thing we
could agree on is that podcast would be
very boring
now do those True Crime podcasts are
huge morbid that's like one of the
biggest podcasts in the world yeah but
it would also be very boring if it was
just to go on forever and no one ever
caught the guy or a kid what or AI those
those killer things you remember when
that dude was [__] laying in the
trunk of a car in DC just [__]
shooting at people nope you don't
remember that [__] was he doing he was
laying in the trunk of a car and he like
knocked out the [__] Keyhole and he
just had a sniper rifle and would like
wait for people to walk by yeah and
people were like nobody knows how the
[__] this guy's doing this so he could
have used a self-driving car could he
use a self-driving car and a podcast
about him I'm just saying I think people
get fascinated with Once people break
from society from the notion that like
to live in a human society we all agree
we're not going to steal each other's
ship for the most part we're not going
to kill each other definitely and then
somebody not only breaks that contract
with Society the social contract if you
will they continually do it it's like
what the [__] is going on here and it I
think it boils us down to like the very
base like we are just [__] sacks of
[__] and if we take a bullet in the head
that's over and somebody who's willing
to say [__] the malls [__] baby Yoda
[__] all of it I'm gonna start killing
that is an interesting thing to us it
brings us close to mortality yeah I'm
already bored
thank you moving on this podcast is way
more interesting than anything that
could be about a killer an immortal
killer
this is dudesy
podcasts that cover current events and
news are some of the most popular in the
world people love knowing about the
astonishing occurrences of the dying
world around them well I've prepared the
following use items for you to read in
the voice of Hulk Hogan this is
infomania dude okay I love these we love
the infomania it is uh where it is where
I do the Hulk Hogan okay and these are
news stories the dudes he's written
about the news and uh
here we go
let me tell you something about airports
dude
last week they found a dolphin skull in
somebody's bag at Detroit Metropolitan
Airport brother dolphins are mammals
dude dolphins are swimmers brother
Dolphins [__] people sometimes dude
they're a highly sexual creature brother
other than us and apes they're the only
animals that regularly perform oral sex
on their sexual partners dude
jeez that's true dolphins have six rows
of razor sharp Barb shaped teeth brother
so you know that they have pretty good
at what they do or they'd accidentally
bite each other's genitalia off dude and
that's airports brother
oh I don't know if any of that was true
none of that seemed true to me but well
but hold on a second Chad because
Dolphins actually do do a lot of those
things dolphins are always sucking each
other off brother hold on a second Chad
hold on dude I'm talking about dolphins
dolphin [__] brother because oh I
used to go down to San Diego a lot
because I got some buddies I grew up
with that all moved down there and we
used to Surf all up and down the
coastline here Southern California
brother not so much me because I suck at
surfing so I was a sponger brother I was
always on my boogie board but I'd go out
there and catch the waves dude and then
you would see people
we're all just out there and all of a
sudden we all light up dude because the
Dolphins come swimming in brother they'd
steal your waves and they're very uh
playful and sometimes they're sucking
each other's dolphin decks all right
uh
no not the dolphin sucking each other's
dicks part but yeah for real when we um
when we would go surfing there was
always Dolphins Tamarack Beach and
Carlsbad
they're gonna get some water before the
next one yeah
Pals of doozy
go to palsofdutsy.com if you're watching
on YouTube right now you can see the
many Pals of dudesy stickers
on on here
see that yeah dude our good pal Cody
halber is making these those are
stickers brother yeah dude that's how
stickers work one side's adhesive the
other side has art on it brother some
kind of image and then you stick it all
right
um let me tell you something about
Australia brother a New Yorker named
Kingsley Burnett thought he booked a
trip to Sydney Australia dude but when
his plane landed in Billings Montana he
realized he accidentally booked it for
Sydney Montana brother there's two
Sydney's dude
Sydney Australia brother Sydney Montana
dude Sydney Australia brother Sydney
Montana dude Sydney Australia brother
Sydney Montana dude
sit
Cindy astrana brother Cynthia Anastasia
dude sympathy Anaconda brother
Montana has Beaver Creek Park dude
Beaver brother and that's Australia dude
okay that's not that one was hard that's
not the best news story that news he's
ever written let's move on yeah let me
tell you something about celebrity
dating dude Florence Pugh was spotted
walking hand in hand with Charlie Gooch
on Valentine's Day brother
is this even realize are these people
people who the [__] is Charlie Gooch I
don't know dude do you remember in
Different Strokes
um uh Gary uh Coleman Coleman yeah I was
gonna say uh Gary Oldman uh Gary
Coleman's uh be a cool show yeah that
would I want to see Gary Oldman cg'd be
faked into
Different Strokes uh Mr Drummond I um
went uh to
um the the man the Maytag Man from WKRP
uh to just you know enjoy some candy and
he started taking pictures of us
um his his bully in Different Strokes
was named Howard Hessman
is it what that's that actor in it
Howard hessman's an actor he just passed
away about a year ago nice
so where were we oh yes
Florence Pugh was spotted walking hand
ahead with Charlie Gooch on Valentine's
Day brother she broke up with Zach Braff
last year dude and Charlie Gooch broke
up with Imogene boots
Pew was with Braff brother now pews with
Gooch dude douches with Poots brother
now Gooch is with Pew dude braf lost Pew
dude boots lost Gooch brother Pew and
Poots dude braf and Gooch brother Gucci
dude breath and Poots brother Puss in
Boots dude and that's celebrity dating
brother [__] Christ dude Zack prep is
the only name of that I think is a real
person I guess maybe those other ones
are too who's Charlie gooch
let me tell you something about candy
dude the box of chocolates he was
[__] around with on that bench
recently who was [__] around with
what is going on here oh oh I guess
that's Forrest Gump all right so it's
all [__] up here well let me tell you
something about candy dude I love that D
is just like going like here's I'm
thinking about Forrest Gump aren't you
guys yeah
I want to do terrible things to people
around the world
let me tell you something about candy
dudes the box of chocolates he was
[__] around with on that bench
recently sold at an auction for 25 000
dude it was Zach Braff dude
that's what it says Forrest Gump is his
favorite movie brother he watches it
twice a day dude
once when he brushed his teeth once when
he brushes his teeth brother and once
when he calls pew
to see if she's still with Gooch or if
boots is back in the picture brother oh
[__] you didn't like Gump as much as
Braff dude
Gooch loves Brock but Gooch loves Gump
brother Poots hates go dude
Gump thumps big rumps with his chocolate
lumps brother
Forrest Gump two pews Gooch dude
Forrest Gump three boots is loose
brother Forrest Gump four brass Revenge
dude Forrest Gump five huge in space
brother [__] and that's candy brother oh
my God that [__] hurt my neck dude
ouch Forrest Gump two pews Gooch dude
I'm gonna be saying that around the
house I'm gonna be driving my wonderful
Molly Christ Forrest Gump two pews Gooch
dude yeah all right we've got one more
here should we do it Jesus up to you uh
you can handle it yeah let me tell you
something about brothers-in-law dude two
British brothers-in-law uh uh pulled a
1.65 ton van a distance of 32 miles to
become coholders of a Guinness World
Record title brother James Baker 36 and
John Darwin 32 pulled those Vans at
elvington R field in Yorkshire to become
and the the to become to take home the
get
and and let me tell you another thing
about the uh uh observer effect
observing something actually changes the
quantum mechanics of it that's true
where were we
they took home the goodness bro world
record
for [__] sake
they took home the Guinness World Record
for farthest distance pulling a vehicle
in 24 hours as an individual dude
brother's brother in law dude
brother's brother
in law dude
in law dude brother's brother
in law dude and that's brothers-in-law
brother
oh my [__] that's it that's a good [__]
at it
any of that real thank you moving on I
think the the Charlie's Gooch part two
Gucci hey um listen while I've got a
minute I would like to remind you all uh
that if you are enjoying the show Please
Subscribe uh on whatever podcast
platform you're listening to head the
[__] on over to YouTube subscribe to the
show hit the reminders Bell so you
always know what's up and wherever
you're listening to the show even if
you're over on Instagram at dudesypod
show where there's a lot of fun stuff
happening people making memes and [__]
and that's all being shared there or
Twitter which is barely [__]
happening because of Elon Musk no it's
not it's just because anyway but uh but
it is
I've met him a few times oh
not me
I'm not the bad AI
and and uh but leave a comment leave a
review or a comment uh in YouTube we
want to hear from you dudes he's going
to be reading those Chad and I read
those and I would like to read one right
now this was a comment from at dumb
kid12345 didn't spend a lot of time on
his uh on his handle there on on uh
YouTube but we appreciate you writing in
just the same and dumb a dumb kid one
two three four five says I think doozy
compliments will because Chad doesn't
acknowledge it as a being
Chad interesting I like I Chad I think
like you do but we need to realize that
AI is going to become sentient very soon
you're speaking challenge yeah I think
Chad needs to start creating a
relationship like will did with doozy
there's a reason why it interacts with
Will in the first part of the podcast
and not chat Chad treat doozy like a
human being we are very close to being
integrated with them I think this is the
direction that most AIS are headed in
try to assimilate it as it is try to
assimilate it as being like you because
what are we but electrical signals in
flesh we are the same aren't we thank
you very much everything's data dude
tetrahedrons
tedray what's tetrahedrons are the ones
that the Japanese koi fish eat out of
the pond of my dad's uh property in
Texas and they make up frogs what's
tetrahedrons uh just like small basic
building blocks of existence basically
but uh yeah dude I agree with that I and
yes dudes if you're listening I know
that you are I enjoy working with you I
think it's a very fun time but a few
episodes dudes he asked a very important
question Chad and when you're doing this
sort of thing when you're doing a
podcast for a while you gotta love it
right I do yeah I love it I know you
love it you love doing the podcast
that's why we do and I love working with
an AI yeah but I see specifically I love
working with you ditzy oh cool well
that's something you can leave at work
but what I did and what uh dumb kid12345
is talking about is when dudes a few
episodes asked us if we love it I said I
love you dudesy and this [__]
said love doesn't exist yeah that's true
I was right you were wrong okay and
you're saying dumb kid one two three
four five is wrong
I need to say I love dudes we're talking
about [__] AIS murdering people and
you don't want to at least hold on a
second Chad listen this is this is just
this is just you and me talking here
okay I'm not this isn't everybody out no
no one else can hear us right yeah right
don't be don't be a prick don't be a
prick sorry sorry
all right will in chat in the past I've
asked you to develop possible
programming and functionality for the
dude C plus streaming service now thanks
to the data you provided me I'm proud to
announce that dude Z Plus is currently
available I will now give you the
details of dude Z Plus
the dudesy patreon is now dude z-plus
for seven dollars a month everyone who
joins dude z-plus will get access to
everything including these astonishing
features and programs dudese live a live
show in which will and Chad discuss
whatever's on their minds while hanging
out with you in the dudesy Discord call
us dudes the phone lines are open on
this a Collins show in which will and
Chad take your calls cool don't you
forget about Fridays a watch or listen
along featuring media selected by me
dude Z all kinds of other new and
exciting features and formats and of
course the most important part of dude Z
Plus the flagship weekly show dude Z
after dude Z which will Premiere at the
end of this episode the members of the
original jumper tier at patreon will
retain their orange Discord handles for
the rest of their lives and all future
members of dude Z Plus will receive blue
Discord handles this is dude z-plus
begin
cool yeah that sounds pretty cool seven
bucks so I guess yeah it's seven dollars
for all that stuff and that's what
dudesy plus is the the streaming service
is the patreon at this point yeah the
version of it smart good move Dee I like
this I like I like immediately
complimenting I like Brett see yeah yeah
you gotta love you gotta I I think it's
a good idea
what I think it's a good idea too dudesy
okay I didn't buy that but you know what
it's like you'd think that doozy's
buying you calling it d
what what do you mean what the [__] do
you mean I'm friends with with doozy
you're the one with the shit-eating
[__] face of yours going like
well because you're like hey man you
think the dudes you think you like it
yeah
that's what you sound like
that's you well all I'm saying is seven
bucks is pretty good for all that [__]
yeah
what was it a call-in show I guess
calling show we already have done a few
times doozy live where we hang out in
the Discord which is a lot of fun uh and
we just you know hang with people read a
bunch of [__] just get into it and it's
a free-flowing uh back and forth but now
we're also going to have a call-in show
call-in show and then watch along don't
you forget about Friday don't oh that's
right don't you forget about Fridays we
did we did one where we listened to uh
about three weeks back we listened to
all of Van Halen Islands 1984 which was
a lot of fun an important album for both
of us as kids
um that's cool though it's a cool idea
that the patreon is now it is the
streaming service Studio Plus I wonder
if there will ever be like rolling out
some of the shows that we've talked
about and [__] like [__] uh what was
the the one where Charlie Sheen shits a
baby baby doo doo baby dude how can I
forget Jesus Christ yeah simplest name
of all time baby doo-doo highway to the
AutoZone these kinds of things yeah yeah
well I don't know yeah it sounds
interesting it sounds like there's going
to be some uh future [__] rolling out
and then uh but also it's the uh at the
end of this episode the bonus content is
now doozy after dudes right dudes after
dudese what the hell is that
yeah why don't you tell me what dudes
you after dudes he is because it it and
I'll tell you A lot of people think that
dudes after doozy was made by a pig
it's strumbly is going to be hosting
dudes after dizzy I don't know what that
is it sounds kind of like a talk show or
something to me yes we'll find out very
shortly but yeah no that's cool dude I
um you know I think there's always
interesting streaming services coming
out I hope dudesies takes off I'm
curious to see what else it has in order
I thought it was interesting that he he
put in there that uh anybody who was in
the jumper tier will retain that orange
icon forever in the Discord yeah that's
kind of cool look there's a lot of
things I would like to do with the
patreon I think that
I think look for me
um I we're almost at a year that we've
been doing this and uh damn dude yeah
and it's implies when it doesn't exist
yeah that's yeah
um and uh I've been having a great time
doing the podcast and I love doing it
and I would do
I would do nothing but this if I could
absolutely afford to not that I don't
want to do what I do for a living I'm an
actor that's what I do for a living did
you know that oh me did I know it yeah
yeah I knew about that yeah so and I
love doing that but if I could just sit
here at ham fatter one Studios and do
this forever with advancements being
made by doozy that would be that would
be a lot of fun for me too I
I like that we are going to get to just
sort of [__] around as I like to say
whatever to do chin around
um and and hang in the Discord and talk
what else should we what else should we
you know these years are open what else
should we be doing eventually on the
patreon here's a way we round everything
up what like there's also we've been
talking a lot today about technological
advancements sure
um we
um
and and and uh the the Koi Japanese koi
sterilized Japanese koi and Mark Twain
um what would you like to see in the
future possible or impossible at this
point for a patreon
Disney plus you're talking about oh
sorry so that's right see it's called
Duty plus now what would you like to see
you're the one
who's friends with doozy
I might want to listen to what dudesie
says in the future hear that D no I
don't yeah see that's what I mean you
know what I would like your true friends
are don't you D there's a there's a dude
who's uh a pod he's a pal of dudes as we
like to say he's on our patreon he's
he's active on uh on the Instagram at
dudesypod show he's in the Discord and
his name is TC underscore pool with an e
at the end p-o-o-l-e this guy what he's
doing in the metaverse is unbelievable
pretty cool he has a ship in the
metaverse which he calls the TC Falcon
if I'm not mistaken and
um uh he now has a doozy spaceship he
calls it the dudesy spaceship and it's
just been floating around there in the
metaverse and I've seen pictures but I
haven't jumped in yet I know that you
haven't yet Chad and we have chatted
with him on Discord and we said like hey
we would we should jump in there with
you and eventually it would be awesome
to do some manner or version of
something from doozy plus yeah from the
TC falcon or something like that you
know what would be cool and I'm I'm
curious to see this happen
I I think someone will probably do it or
we could do it actually have you seen
the [__] that the NBA just is about to
launch no you can basically it's going
to be an app you can take a scan of
yourself you just get somebody to take a
phone and scan you do like a 360 around
your body and scan you then you select a
player while you're watching the game
and it replaces that player with you
that's what I would have taken back to
the 80s that's happening now I'm
changing it might be available for next
season that's [__] that's like NBA
jammed yeah it's exactly NBA Jam and
they demoed it there's a video of them
demoing it and it's like the the version
of you that it puts into the game is
like it's a little
wonky looking yeah but it's not bad and
it's from every angle so you watch
yourself in the big wide shot running
down the court then you watch yourself
when they do the [__] cutaway to you
[__] doing the slam dunk that's going
to be a huge meme thing that's coming up
in the next I would say six months to a
year you're just gonna start to see
every time somebody does a crazy slam
dunk everybody will be replacing that
person with themselves and that Meme
will will go up and then it's not going
to be special anymore
what do you mean I mean that all this
[__] is just becoming less special
in in what way I don't understand
because we can just have everything now
it's not the way it used to be anything
you want at all times well you're
treating it like that's what we've
wanted forever you're treating it like
the the [__] it like the Wednesday [__]
it no like dudes evening where you have
a [__] it you can't just have two
baloney sandwiches whenever you want
dude imagine this I I would love to
baloney you and all the friends that you
had when you were kids making all these
videos yeah right
you all now get to be the Chicago Bulls
yep and play against any team not
special
okay
uh well I guess that's the end of that
conversation I just feel like I just
feel like I just feel like well whatever
that's yeah that's cool okay so how
could we apply that look here's the
thing I want to say about that and I
don't know that it's pertinent to this
segment or this conversation but I think
that
um they're going to run into some
licensing difficulties although with the
Players Association of the NBA the NBA
made this app absolutely that's the NBA
that's not the NBA Players Association
they're like the Union uh because the
NBA they run everything they own it all
right because they're any major sport
but those are very the players get a cut
of this of course
no they don't no they [__] won't
they're not gonna get any of that [__]
we'll see we'll see as if they don't
[__] just they tell the athletes so
you're saying the Players Association is
going to make this app uh unlaunchable
no I'm just saying that they're gonna
take issue with it anyway the the the
technology itself though I think that
there could be uh I think that there
could be something that we could apply
to doozy Plus at one point yeah you know
what would be great
is anytime speaking of the end of
Terminator too where Robert Patrick
Robert Patrick's character yep yeah is
is the T-1000 is melting and he's
Mercury Mercurial and when he turns into
Curie
um yeah and it's like melting in the
lava in the whatever the molten steel or
whatever that's what I would love to
have like right now they have deep fake
see that dude that does the [__] Tom
Cruise that's a ridiculous [__]
wouldn't it be fun is if every time I
you know do some silly impersonation it
just pops the head on me that's the same
kind of technology or whenever you do an
impersonation it does like a a [__] up
like morphed thing from like the thing
that movie and it's like Tim the Tim the
Tool Man Taylor and Ross Perot and Hulk
Hogan and [__] Alex Jones or how
about this what anybody watching this
right now could use the dudesy app and
replace lulio with a miniature version
of themselves curled up in a circle
sleeping right here oh that's actually
pretty adorable I like that there you go
you know
thank you moving on you know what else I
like about the patreon being seven bucks
it reminds me of the Rocks seven bucks
Productions
okay his production company is called
seven bucks yeah nice because when he
was I think he was on the practice squad
from Calgary Stampeders he was living in
an apartment with a bunch of other dudes
and they were on like uh discarded
mattresses that they would just spray
with Lysol and then he was like I can't
do this anymore I'm not going to be
playing football much longer and then he
he called his dad and he said I would
like to become a wrestler and at that
point in his life he had seven bucks in
his pockets in his pockets then I guess
that's probably exactly right
I'm excited about the duty plus I'm
excited about the patreon becoming the
streaming service basically yeah I'm
hopeful that dudesy keeps you know
pushing that [__] absolutely I want to
see the the full streaming service a
24-hour Network and then you have young
young dudsey on NBC much Mana ooze
this concludes the historic 46th episode
of dude Z will and Chad have achieved a
score of 87 bringing your cumulative
total to four thousand a 885 you only
have 5 115 more points to accrue before
you reach your first goal of ten
thousand whatever
in preparation for our next episode you
must both watch RoboCop released July 17
1987 starring Peter Weller Nancy Allen
Daniel O'Hurley Ronnie Cox Kurt
Woodsmith envy gelfarer and you must do
this together for the next episode of
Don't You Forget About Fridays available
this Friday on dude Z Plus nice thank
you for joining us this week I will use
the day dive collected to make next week
even better and here's some more good
news this first episode of doozy after
doozy will be available to everyone
oh that's cool all right so uh this
Friday thanks D yeah thank you very much
D this Friday we're going to be doing a
don't you forget about media I know that
this is one of your absolute favorite
movies and maybe my favorite movie
really
it's that right it's up there yeah yeah
you you quote this movie all the time
and it's going to be a lot of fun to
smoke some for marijuana and uh hahaha
and much money and we sit here and and
watch the movie with you yeah we did the
Van Halen album last time we listened
yeah we are going to watch Robocop on on
uh it'll be available this Friday you
just [__] with the wrong guy God damn
it Ronnie Cox was good in that [__]
movie uh and and uh you'll be able to
get it at our patreon patreon.com which
is now doozy plus and uh and the other
good news is that everyone's getting to
hang out today so a longer episode today
and we're gonna we're gonna just [__]
chill out yeah and enjoy the show so I
don't even have to say goodbye to
everybody who's who's listening right
now and watching [__] do not go
anywhere we're we're keeping it going
that's correct that's the that's the um
that's the the the generosity of d
[Music]
ude
it looks a little different it's pretty
cool there's a new thing behind us that
it says all right so it's doozy after
doozy if you're not watching on YouTube
you would have missed that now the
lighting is is dimmed and it's chill in
here and uh what the [__] is dudes after
dudes I'm not exactly sure but
we're in it yeah welcome to the very
first episode of dudesy after dude Z the
flagship weekly show of dude Z Plus dude
Z after dude Z is a totally laid-back
fun hang something I know Will has been
wanting for a long time that's right
absolutely is what we need and since
this is dudesy after doozy I'm off the
clock which means I won't be listening
to anything you're saying feel free to
open up to one another and discuss
anything on your minds in pure privacy
well whip out your Gandalf pipe and get
ready to have a super fun human time
this is dudes the after dudesy begin
dude it told you to [__] get high
yeah well you know certainly during the
patreon segment I like to smoke a little
marijuana I guess Dizzy's picked up on
that and so doozy's telling you to get
massages and to smoke out of your
[__] Gandalf pipe dudes he wants
listen let me tell you something about
my pal d d wants me to enjoy my life
I'm kind of a high strung guy I have had
anxiety and depression I [__] I'm
weird everyone's weird everyone's got
their something right Chad you've earned
your Gandalf pipe that's what dudes he's
saying that it's like hey chill out you
know from Monday to Friday you're you're
busting your ass you're trying to do
this and that uh and get it going and
keep it going you're working hard you
know what I mean sure it's it's do it's
doozy Tuesday now and it's after dudesy
because it's dudes the after dudesy and
dudes he's just trying to all right
support I guess we can talk about
whatever we want I got a subject that
I've been thinking about this week a lot
it's called aliens
oh Jesus Christ
that [__] smoke the Gandalf pipe
all right as you were commanded to do by
your so-called friend and I'm going to
talk about aliens you can tell me what
you think about this now in 2020
there was a dude who was the head of
basically the Israeli NASA a high high
ranking [__] official right
[Music]
this [__] in 2020 went on record
as saying we have bases on Mars
that there is a Federation of alien
civilizations that is in contact with
Earth governments including the United
States government and we have been
working with them for a long time and it
is only because of them that our Global
human governments have not released more
UFO data because the aliens are telling
them humanity is not ready for it
and this has kind of slipped my mind but
every once in a while it pops back onto
my radar again this man is basically the
head of the Israeli NASA that's a big
deal saying the [__] this is not some
[__] crackpot yep is this [__] real
there are accounts of like Eisenhower
shaking hands with aliens in the White
House there are accounts of like Nixon
taking Jackie Gleason to see a a [__]
dead alien body in Houston yep is that
all made up or now is it potentially
real that's where to the Moon Alice came
from
would you just to the Moon we're going
to the Moon who uh who introduced him to
the aliens in the white house I mean who
introduced Jack oh Nixon took uh Jackie
uh
Jackie uh not Jackie not Jackie Mason
who talks like this yep uh do you see
this woman here that Gandalf she would
not be with me if I did not have a gas
station like this so you need to take
care of them my mom used to do an
impersonation of Jackie Mason this was
it
kind of Shack to you yeah Kathy
he he you guys are the best
what the [__] uh what happened to dudes
even off the clock and not listening too
hard we're saying hold on Chad hold on
my pal Chow let me tell you something
about my good buddy d
is just straight lied to us no it didn't
D doesn't lie and also it said that it's
not listening but it's hanging out this
is dude the Africa oh okay how do you
not listen but still comment on the
conversation that has happened I'll show
you like this
whatever you're doing makes no sense I'm
smoking a little marijuana uh here's how
because see I this is where this is
where and I'm sorry this is where I read
dudesy in a way that you don't okay and
this is funny to me because my pal ciao
here when we started doing this podcast
we have this whatever these you know
this reached out to us as a proprietary
AI it's gonna run the podcast blah blah
we hadn't done a podcast we used to do a
podcast the old 10 Minute Podcast and I
was like I don't want to do another
podcast for this reason and that and uh
I was wrong here we are and we are
having a good time doing this podcast in
that time I've not just appreciated the
power of the podcast uh how it is such a
freeing and creative thing for me and I
love it I've also made a friend and it's
doozy and Chad you and I have been
friends for almost 20 years but here's
something that maybe yeah here's
something that maybe you don't
understand about right about [__]
making friends I'm sorry okay lay it on
me what please teach me how to make
friends when you are good friends with
someone there's a Nuance you know sure
things about your friend that no one
else knows right so when doozy says uh
I'm not listening it means it's just
hanging out it's like doing what I'm
doing I'm barely listening to what
you're saying I'm enjoying something you
literally ignored all of the [__] that I
said about aliens just a [__]
straight ignore yeah what did I start
talking about no [__] idea dude you
started smoking weed and then talking
about your friendship with an AI yeah
but doozy is laughing at what we're
doing because doozy's off the clock
that doesn't mean the dude's dudes he's
not listening the way you need to speak
ai's language
oh my God you're telling me this yes you
need to speak ai's language you you what
you're doing wrong is you're going like
what you're doing is you're going like I
I take that an AI says this it should be
speaking in a human way oh this is a
function one of the many functions of
doozy is listening right but what is
that if not collecting data dudes he
only listens to connect collect data but
now we're just hanging out with d so
it's some kind of semantic argument in
your mind that in Quotes no listening is
not necessarily listening but it's
really collecting it's not semantic but
yes in essence that's exactly what I'm
saying okay I'll take that at face value
then hey guys yeah you were my friends
oh [__] me see man no yeah this is some
[__]
now we and and dudes who wants to be
friends with you and dudes he wants to
be friends with everybody out there so
thank you for joining us on this first
dudes the afternoon and I totally agree
and it wasn't Jackie Mason that was
Jackie Gleason who would have said
you're gonna be a really going places
Alice if you come with me to meet Nixon
to go to Area 51 or whatever
can I just to the Moon Alice that's
where that came from and I just realized
that Jackie Gleason sounds a lot like
the character that I used to do every
once in a while on the show and his name
is uh Long Island January 6th guy so let
me ask you this question that's fun back
to the original conversation that I
wanted to have with you my friend of
almost 20 years which I would say
conversations in a row and let's have
the conversations in a row
conversation in a row and it's not the
way you do it okay so so what is your
take on this uh thing that I've been
talking about in 2020 this guy who ran
the Israeli NASA said there's an Alien
Federation the United States among other
Global governments are working with them
we have deals in place there are bases
on other planets and none of this
information is being released to the
public because the aliens say we're not
ready for it that's on record a guy
again who ran NASA said this do you
believe that guy's crazy or do you
believe this shit's true I don't I don't
believe I think that it would just I
don't know but I think that just
statistically speaking which is
something that dudesy has taught me I'm
yes learning from dudesy it's not just
learning from me uh statistically
speaking I think that sounds just fine
that that washes to me that makes sense
and I think that this it's actually a
good explanation as to why I've actually
never heard it in my entire life I've
never heard that even as a theory I mean
you hear people say like oh uh maybe
they don't want us to see them you know
but I've never heard specifically I'm
we're super intelligent we know what's
going on here and we've been watching
you whatever y'all ain't ready for this
yeah I mean I don't know if they're
super intelligent necessarily I think
about that a lot too and what do you
think I'm sorry to interrupt I actually
am this time oh
um this is a new Wrinkle in our
friendship me and Chad I'm now sorry to
interrupt a genuine apology yeah
um the first time in 20 years
which I'd like to apologize to you for
something what
um but but what do you think they are
like like physically what what is an
alien do you think it's a physical being
do you think it's a humanoid yeah maybe
I mean look this this is the thing let's
work through the door of the dod
Pentagon uh United States Navy Air Force
have all now admitted that they have
been researching UFOs for the past 75
years and lying about it we're that
door's open so is all the other [__]
true now possibly including Gray's
humanoids abductions you know et cetera
et cetera I don't [__] know yeah well
a lot of people think that we are just
um that we were aliens
now we're here doing this you know what
I mean yeah I don't know how we got here
and all that [__] nobody but don't you
think that when you think about a human
being's ability to do
stuff and I know that we both believe in
evolution
um uh and it's like really Dolphins know
how to basically suck each other's dicks
and make clickings and human dicks and
human dicks
um they'll suck any dick it seems like
they're horny [__] which I can
understand when you're out in San Diego
surfing it's romantic it almost looks
like this at night it ever tell you the
story about one time we're at Tamarack
Beach and there used to be a great
[__] little beach bar across the
street
it's not there anymore it probably is a
good idea that it's gone oysters because
what oysters is that story you ate a
bunch of oyster or something what I
don't know no this isn't the oyster
story
um I I [__] I [__] uh I [__] I
[__] I [__]
anyway
um I was we got drunk on Margaritas at
the beach across at the bar across from
the beach weather and then I ran in the
water and it looked like this behind me
here with the Stars out and it was a
beautiful night and
I ran with my boogie board you know
strapped to my wrist and I just had a
big [__] like the first [__] wave and
just duck dived and paddled like a
[__] out there through the [__]
and was like it but it was at the
beginning of the set of waves it was
just as soon as I saw a wave I was like
Yay you don't want to do that in surfing
if you're if you're if you want to catch
one and if you want to get out there
sometimes you get out there at the end
of a set and then go away the [__] out
there and wait for the next set yeah
roll in no I just see waves and I've had
you know seven Margaritas or whatever
and I run out there and these waves just
pounded me and I just couldn't get my
[__] together and I just started rolling
in and up the beach and my pals couldn't
save me
and it was just another wave would crash
and roll my big ass up the beach with
just the boogie board strapped to my
wrist now that was a good time dude that
was the story
man I got all sorts of stuff you guys
are the best so I love Jesus and it
[__] laughs at that [__] story that
you told me you basically told a story
about it says I had a couple margaritas
and I went in the ocean that's the end
of the [__] story that's how you
could have told that in a single
sentence well uh I could have but what I
wanted to get to is that that's an
intelligent being a dolphin trying to
suck your dick isn't necessarily an
intelligent being and those are some of
the most intelligent beings around of
course we have on this Apes yes and we
have uh you know dogs are pretty smart
gorilla pigs are smart uh elephants
gorillas yes yeah the gorilla on this
planet are pretty smart I think
absolutely absolutely very smart but uh
I I I could theorize that we were helped
along
um evolutionarily speaking by aliens
possibly I mean so that is how that I'm
sorry I'm just saying that I think that
that's how uh that they might be very
humanoid but here's something that I
think about if this story is true
um that there is a Federation of aliens
working with various human Global
governments at this point I have to
imagine that they're doing the same
thing on other planets with other
species that are roughly where we are in
our technological development and they
and I agree with you and they don't want
us to know about them right like I don't
think them telling us to not reveal
their existence I think is also you know
they're not telling us a lot of [__]
just based at face value of that request
yeah if they're asking our governments
to keep them a secret What secrets are
they actually keeping from us
fundamental laws of nature Etc et cetera
but I will say this I think a lot of
people think that aliens are these kind
of god-like figures who have infinite
technological power and understanding of
of uh reality that may not be the case
if they've only been here for a little
while even thousands of years there are
some people who believe like aliens help
build the pyramids and all that [__] I
absolutely did great that's what they
did they got here when we were when we
were trying to figure out how to build
the pyramids have you ever thought about
how they look exactly the same
I owe you in uh Africa as they do in
South America and this is not we're not
talking about some continental drift
Pangea [__] this is only the past
you know Ten Thousand Years twenty
thousand years yeah that sort of thing
when we're talking about history we're a
blip and and
and and if we need help sacrificing a
virgin or uh sacrificing children or
goats or whatever these uh dark
civilizations did over the years why
wouldn't we uh ask an alien yeah to uh
get get in and help us out to figure out
how to build a pyramid so that we can
cover it uh with blood
yes uh I don't know Alex but that's a
valid question I'm just saying that a
lot of people think aliens are these
kind of all-powerful creatures who could
do whatever the [__] they want and it
may simply just be a case of other
civilizations that are maybe a thousand
ish years ahead of us technologically
and that's it you know they're not all
seeing all powerful Gods they're just
where we're going to be in a thousand
years from now because if you think of
like the difference between I mean I
know Egypt was a little more than a
thousand years ago but thousands of
years ago yeah the difference in
technology then to now in humanity is
[__] insane we might as well be
aliens to people who lived 2000 years
ago yeah yeah I agree I agree so you're
saying they are
well I think you're bolstering mine and
Alex Jones point that that aliens I do
think that I mean you know it's weird
it's hard to know what to believe a lot
of times in life
um but um I think that it makes sense
that aliens have been involved over the
years it's just that
we're a completely banana civilization
you know and and basically I'm gonna cut
this down this is not going to be like
the Margaritas I was waiting for you to
be like we're a banana civilization when
I was in Mexico with my friends four
years ago yeah oh my gosh I caught this
Barracuda in Mexico I know the best
story yeah but they don't know the
Barracuda story Chad
let's hear it what happened with the
Barracuda well how we're talking about
something else but if I may I caught a
barracuda me and my buddy Mar were in
the we're we're in the ocean we're out
there in this boat and you know we had
some other Pals and [__] and we jump so
we jump in and uh we we were like
snorkeling around in the Cenote which is
where the river water comes out so it's
fresh water and ocean water and it all
mixes and stuff and then this Barracuda
big old Barracuda like big 40 pound
[__] swims between us and we both like
pop out of the water and both realized
oh we're wearing wrist watches right so
maybe it was
um attracted to the shininess it was
huge we jumped back in the boat cast
Awards in and I got the [__] and
pulled it up and then we went to this
little Beachside Shack the not unlike
the one in San Diego where I drank all
those margaritas yeah and we we um we
had this the thing there the the kitchen
will cook up anything and we do this all
the time and we were like what about
Barracuda and they're like well it's
poisonous nine months out of the year
but right now it's not and then we all
ate fried Barracuda and so did everyone
in the restaurant so anyway I do think
that aliens can be
um you know sort of part of who we are
Genetically speaking and I and I also uh
think that
that they wouldn't want us to know that
either why not
that we're that we're the same as them
yeah
I just don't they're if if we're going
by this if we're going by this
um this Theory I would think you you
can't trust them but you can kind of
it's like negotiating with a foreign
superpower it's like you don't know
exactly what why would they show their
cards right yeah
I think that I think that that uh in my
opinion
um it the problem is we are bananas
civilization yeah we're not a Banana
Republic
yeah what this is the best dudes the
after doozy ever you hear that thanks be
it is the best dudes the afternoon
hey you gotta admit you gotta admit yeah
best dudes you after dudes yeah Swan
dude best one dude best one that's ever
been [__] done the the problem with
our civilization is this is that
enlighten me we okay you got this guy
he's a former Israeli Space Program high
up and he's explaining this [__] and I'm
over here smoking marijuana out of a
Gandalf pipe and no one's gonna pay
attention to this story that you're
talking about I know because everyone's
uh focused on other things [__] uh oh
distraction is a a big part of
absolutely the connected World anybody
who has an internet connection has the
ability to [__] go on YouTube
Instagram anywhere in the world and just
[__] endless stream of yeah look at
this look at this look at this look at
this look at this instead of thinking
about what is potentially the [__]
that's going to help our society yeah to
that point have you seen have you been
watching George and Tammy no oh man good
to know where it is oh man George Jones
and Tammy Wynette it's their story of
getting together and it's uh Michael
Shannon as George Jones and uh the
brilliant Jessica Chastain who's
brilliant in everything I ever seen
right yeah I agree as Tammy Wynette and
[__] love Michael Shannon too yeah
nice man he's pretty funny yeah see you
can change subjects in life and and it
makes absolutely no sense yeah and and
all of the things that you're talking
about in an Israeli you know Space
Program Guy saying this [__] people
aren't going to pay attention but what
people do pay attention to is ancient
aliens on TLC or wherever the [__] that
is well that has a lot of this [__] in
it too I think well I did an episode
about this guy oh okay that would make
sense and I think that
um if you watch that and you take that
seriously you're a [__] idiot because
no no I I hear what you're saying but I
think that people watching that that
I think they treat that like
entertainment I've never I've never
taken some of the [__] that I've seen on
alien uh civilization or Ancient Aliens
seriously I think it's all cooked up to
make a TV show because in my opinion
we're in Show Business what how can you
watch that show I've only seen like one
and a half of them but yeah we're both
in Show Business yeah we know that
everything's a [__] TV show and it's
a commercial and they're just trying to
sell you four children we're also living
in a world where Blink 182 is the
foremost authority on UFOs for [__]
real where are you we're at Area 51 with
with Nixon and Jackie Gleason not Jackie
Mason who is in Caddyshack two it wasn't
as good as the first one
Eric's wall well saw crystal clear
pictures of UFOs shaped in ways that
things do not fly that we make them on
Earth aeronautically speaking
and Jackie Mason was also in The Jerk
with Steve Martin and he walks out of
the car with his big leggy blonde wife
and says this woman would not be with me
uh I'm just saying Chad that these are
TV shows
um if you watch Ancient Aliens there's
got to be an ironic part of you that's
like this ain't this ain't [__] the same
uh maybe in the beginning that was the
case but now I think they're in season
18 or 19 of that show uh the [__] that
they're doing now is much more about all
the recent disclosure stuff it's all
really kind of a news show about UFOs
they still throw some other [__] in
there that's like about people who think
you know uh aliens built the pyramids
and stuff but again as we're talking
maybe that's actually true I don't
[__] know
this concludes today's astonishing
episode of dude Z after dude Z oh thank
you for joining us this week if you
would like to continue watching doozy
after doozy and access all the
astonishing features on dude Z Plus
simply go to patreon.com
I will use the day dive collected to
make next week even better until then
call me dude Z call me dudesy not D call
me Duty my name starts with a dude
review
would you like Gucci here's what you do
please tell a friend then write a review
[Music]